all right here with reaction former
Arkansas Governor Mike Huckabee is with
us Governor great to have you
been our workers are building electric
buses so people can get where they need
to go
as as as the name suggests Community
Banks there for communities
the passage of time is about time
passing and we're all passing through
time through the passage of time
now if it happened once or twice I might
be able to comprehend it but it seems to
happen every time she opens her mouth
and and why does every American kind of
feel like they're being lectured as a
kindergartner uh by the vice president
if she's not giggling uncontrollably
I think she knows more about passing a
kidney stone than passing of time I've
never seen anybody who is unable to put
a sentence together and the sad thing is
our taxes are paying a speechwriter to
write that stuff for her that's what
makes it sad wow I mean it is amazing
Tudor Dixon also with us former Michigan
uh gubernatorial candidate tutor what's
your take
that are we have our taxpayers that are
paying for these speeches to be written
and to be given but I want you to know
that I've seen her lately out in the
media as you were talking about her
latest interviews have been softballs
for her to be out there and look vice
presidential and they've been talking
about abortion it's their favorite
subject she did really well on it she
came out she sounded empathetic she
sounded like she understood the woman's
plate she even said something that was
key and and Governor Huckabee will know
that this is key she said even if you
are concerned about your faith don't
worry you can still say the government
should not be involved in this decision
she's giving women who want permission
to walk away from that part of their
faith can I say this is okay they're
giving she's giving them permission
because you're both pro-life we saw the
vote in Ohio and I will tell you that if
you look at Doug mastriano and and tutor
even your race I would argue that people
that have very restrictive views on
abortion unlike say Mississippi as of 15
weeks that seems to be that was the
Dobbs decision
um that any anything less than that uh
the fear among many many conservatives
is this will chase away many Suburban
voters do you agree with that Mike
Huckabee
I do not I think the problem is
Republicans have done a very pitiful job
of explaining that the difference is we
want to protect life Democrats want to
take it right up to the point of birth
they want to butcher a fully developed
child we've got to take it to the
Democrats quit playing defense let's be
clear about what we stand for and it is
that every human life has worth value
and there's no such thing as an
Expendable or disposable human being
last word
their message is very strong on this
they've won over women we saw it we just
saw it in Ohio we have to start fighting
on the cultural side of it and we have
to fight on the issues that matter to
people politically on the political side
in a different way I think the American
people and I'm I consider myself
pro-life I believe in the sanctity of
life but I think politically that there
is Republicans have gotta say as Bill
Clinton once said I never thought I'd
quote him uh
rare legal and I'd add the word very
early in a pregnancy that seems to be
politically where the country is Maybe
I'm Wrong uh but we'll see that that
vote in Ohio was pretty pretty sobering
all right straight ahead thank you both
Biden hey Sean Hannity here hey click
here to subscribe to Fox News YouTube
page and catch our hottest interviews
and most compelling analysis you will
not get it anywhere else